hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream 128 q and a it is
saturday afternoon rainey is all get out
here no end of may it's dark it's dreary
it's ridiculous there are a lot of
things flowering two years ago
as we descended into covet madness i as
long-term viewers of
the dark horse livestreams will remember
i brought in like
25 or 30 cubic yards of a mixture of
soil and mulch and
rocks for the driveway as well and for
the bioswale
but mostly various soils and composts
and and just a lot of plants and
last year they didn't flower so much but
this year they were actually flowering
really nicely and now the rain is
causing most of the blossoms to fall
into the ground
get eaten by slugs
yeah luck of the draw i did notice while
we had the windows it's now gotten
chilly in here but while we had the
windows open i noticed that because
the maples are now all leafed out
that if you close your eyes and you
listen to it raining out there you know
that sound at a field station in the
tropics when it's raining really hard
out
and you can hear all of the drips on the
big leaves it sounds very different here
in the winter
but uh now we've got um yep yep
we've got a
largely in the winter it's an entirely
uh evergreen forest obviously
yeah and uh
and yeah the big leaf maples which are
the dominant
deciduous tree here uh are fully leafed
out and the raindrops on them is
distinctive it's distinctive so
uh when we ended our live stream just
now
i
took my phone out of airplane mode and
found the following text from my mother
who has said yes i may share that she
says fyi i have already marked michael
shellenberger on my california ballot
which i will turn in next week nice to
know you agree with me hmm
so nice that's cool
um
maybe the entire west coast can get a
grip
wow wouldn't it be something wouldn't
that be something if we could just get a
grip again yeah yeah getting a grip
would be yeah i'd be for it yeah yeah
okay
um this week we have two questions from
the discord uh which as you know as as
as many of you know
uh
people get access to our discord by
joining either of our patreons and
uh each week they vote on their favorite
question that they have that they want
us to answer and i said because we've
been away for a few weeks give us two
this week so they've given us two
the first one is
sociopaths are generally a menace to
human society but is there a reason that
sociopathic traits have persisted and my
individuals who are intolerable by
today's standards have been beneficial
to our ancestors nice yeah
so i have two things to say on this
topic
one is i think we get sociopathy wrong
so first of all i would say sociopathy
is probably adaptive
psychopathy
and the distinction between them is not
100 clear but is a extreme version of
sociopathy probably isn't it's probably
the malignant version but what i think
we get wrong about sociopathy and just
to be clear i mean you've said it i've
said it we've all said it every
evolutionary biologist said it a million
times when you say adaptive
you don't mean awesome
you don't mean good for humans you don't
mean good for society you don't mean we
ra raw we all want more of that yeah no
i don't mean any of those things right
what i mean is that shaped by selection
for a fitness enhancing purpose
um so i'm saying
psychopathy probably not sociopathy yes
but how so right
a i think we get sociopathy wrong
because we tend to say that person is a
sociopath and that person isn't a
sociopath
the problem with that
is that we all love these narratives
where the mob boss is perfectly capable
of ordering
the murders of people who he needs to
disappear and we say ah that's sociopath
but then the mob boss
uh has a deep commitment to his family
and
the question is is sociopathy something
that needs
a refinement so that we can talk about
facultative sociopathy and are we all
facultatively sociopathic with result of
things with the reference to things that
are so remote that we do not feel them
personally i mean is that a possibility
well and is it possible that um you know
one of the distinctions you know a lot
of ink has been spilled over the
distinction between sociopathy and
psychopathy and whether or not it's
actually a meaningful distinction in all
of this
and
given your invoking of facultativeness
which is your biology speak for um under
some environmental conditions that
happens that there's some under other
environmental conditions it doesn't so
for instance we talk about like
facultative versus obligate
pedomorphosis and salamanders do you or
do you not metamorphose and turn into an
adult-looking form or do you not and do
you retain all of your juvenile looking
characteristics in some species obligate
metamorphosis you never lose your gills
and your webbing between your feet and
some facultative depending on what kind
of environment you're in it might be
better to metamorphose and move on to
land or it might be better to retain a
bunch of your larval characteristics to
stay in the water facultative
facultative sociopathy
which is what you're talking about as
sort of a personality trait in which
there might be conditions in which it is
or is not more adaptive for you even
though it will still be bad for almost
everyone around you um maybe psychopathy
could be understood as obligate
sociopathy
yeah i agree that that's one way to do
it but i i actually the problem is that
the
distinction appears to be you know
experts in this will say that
you know a sociopath is perfectly
capable of being completely cold about
something like murder but they don't
delight in it the psychopath made
delight in it right so
there are two parameters one of them is
facultative versus obligate and the
other is how extreme this coldness is i
guess that sounds like
i don't you know i always wonder how
good these categories are right but uh
right
but that but it sounds like that you
know the the delights in it is just
actually an addition of another kind of
personality disorder yep right rather
than you know that doesn't feel like
farther along this it's like this plus
you know sadism well yes but it may be
that it um
you take somebody who has this unusual
coldness and you put them in an
environment in which they get rewarded
for
using it as a tool yeah and do they
become the other
speaking of the least cold least
statistic least sociopathic organism
representative of the least sociopathic
species on the planet yep here we have
madison we have madison the uh the
marvelous dog um but here here's the
other so i've made one argument here
which is that we need some mechanism for
dealing with people who are functionally
sociopathic in one context but not
another they may love their family they
may be murderous mob bosses at work
but somehow those two things exist in
the same character the other thing
though
is that i believe that to the extent
even for obligate sociopaths or possibly
psychopaths if that's the way that
taxonomy works out there's a question
about
is the problem a novelty problem in
other words
maybe soldiers who have played a very
important role in lineage well-being
are effectively
sociopathic but pointed outwards i've
always suspected that sociopathy
is a disorder because
the environment causes it to emerge
where it shouldn't be
but that if your soldiers were
effectively
engaging in that coldness in order to
destroy an enemy that was a threat to
you you might feel very differently
about them right and you might throw
them a parade when they got home and
then that would also make some sense of
the facultative because hopefully when
they get home they're not that way about
you know their fight over the uh you
know who
hit the last piece of pizza
for example i was thinking more of a
fight with their neighbor over something
involving the trimming hedge trimming
for example
right we instantly have had no pizza in
the house for a while so this is in no
way uh apropos any ongoing discussion
between us
not no no we haven't um
anyway you kind of get the idea though
we need a richer concept of sociopathy
in order to have the discussion properly
um but yes i think it shows the
hallmarks of an adaptation but it's not
adapted the way we see it it shows up uh
haphazardly and very destructively and
worst of all
it provides in the in a market context
the freedom from
shared but informal moral structures
provides an advantage to those who have
that capacity to deploy in market space
so what we have is a system that favors
the elaboration of this trade where our
communities would be much better off if
actually that trait was costly when you
deployed it at home
i don't mean in your home but i mean at
home like not fighting an enemy on a
battlefield yep
all right
next question
also from the discord this week
you mentioned that you are worried about
what might be coming in the fall
can you say more about that are there
things regular people should be doing
now
to prepare
yeah
um
i'm more worried than when i said that
because now in addition to
the
intractable
calamity that we have over roe v wade
and its
possible elimination and
[Music]
all of the things that would flow from
that we also now have
um the second amendment back uh in a
active
uh role in our national conversation but
you skipped over the the primary issue
would you like
absent the last two years of covet
misdis and male information from the
authorities who would have us believe
that it's us who are engaging in the
misdismal information um and policy and
all of this stuff absent that even
uh the the potential for roe being
overturned and the re-upping of
discussion over over gun rights
um
and you know even
midterms that are likely to be fraught
after an election that brought into
office someone who no one ever sees
because is he even competent all of this
would probably not be sufficient to have
you have made such a pronouncement it's
the covet madness that um puts
everything
in in a very tenuous
tenuous position with a lot of people
kind of going like see no evil hear no
evil
i forgot one speak
um
and
a lot of people sort of you know
shouting into the wind going but you
can't forget what's going on here
because they will they will march again
yep so there's covid which is not um
behaving
seasonally the way one might expect
um there's the coveted madness um the
governmental response to it and the
demonizing of
individuals there's the possibility that
something will supplant kovid because
people are sick and tired of it um
and that it will be a new topic but same
playbook but anyway
oh and there's you know basically just
the
midterm
issue the fact that all of these things
play into an environment in which
the blue team in the u.s is back on its
heels but
has a number of these killer issues at
its disposal and is going to play a very
dirty game
and so anyway yes i'm concerned about
all of that what can you do uh somebody
at the conference i was just at said
something interesting was nick hudson i
believe
who is a
very broad-minded
private equity guy um anyway a very
technically oriented interesting thinker
and somebody asked him
wasn't me somebody asked him uh what
would you invest in in this in this
crazy moment and he said
people i would invest in relationships
yeah which uh i thought was a very good
answer um
i think the basic point is and we've we
saw this if you look backwards over cove
that you and i have said many times
that people who had a reality check at
home were in a very different situation
than people who were isolated by virtue
of the fact that they didn't have a
significant other right anybody who had
to
fit in and couldn't you know look
somebody in the eye and say this is
crazy isn't it
um within a predicament so that
principle
is i think extensible outwards and to
the extent that you can get a group of
people
that are committed to trying to make
sense rather than trying to leap to
whatever conclusion is being handed them
so they can be you know at the head of
the parade
that would be very very worthwhile now
of course
there's also the other questions you
know
what is
the role of
self-protection
in an environment where
you know we now have
mandates used to purge
independent-minded people who will
refuse immoral orders from
governmental
enforcement structures
you know there's that and there's uh
you know what what resources allow you
to endure uncertain times and you know
it's possible that we should
talk about those things at some point
but in general i would just say
stop assuming that what has typically
worked is going to continue to work we
have seen those things all show signs of
ricketiness
and um
to the extent that you have
considered
what makes you vulnerable and how to
make yourself less vulnerable i would
say it's that moment
yeah
so
for a few years we've been we've been
hearing
about coming and then actual and then
things are attributed to but maybe they
aren't actually about supply chain
issues yeah
and um that now is um perhaps including
food
and
uh
somehow we've been told and many people
seem to be believing that this is all
because of putin
it's like
i don't i don't know who's believing
that um who who must have been
completely asleep
completely brain dead for all of all of
the time leading up to
was it february
of this year um when when putin invaded
ukraine um but there's there's all sorts
of things that we are being told to be
worried about now that maybe we should
have been worried about before but now
because there's a different cover story
that doesn't have to do with insane
covet policy what has to do with you
know russian strong men were allowed to
say yeah there might be a problem here
so um
you know having the ability to to feed
yourself under circumstances where you
might not have previously been able to
would likely be useful
[Music]
all right next question
this is a big one it's not exactly a
question
childhood trauma ptsd healing and
recovery with an evolutionary lens
please
love you guys never miss a week
all right i've got a couple things
okay um
one i would say and you know there are
people who know ptsd
well academically i have never studied
it but i have studied corollary stuff
stuff related to it
and it has always struck me that the
interesting thing
is that the mind can can adjust itself
to a radical transition and what it has
trouble with is
coming back and unremembering this right
so you can be taken to a battlefield and
you can learn that there can be snipers
anywhere
and you can adapt to that and then you
come home and you try to go shopping and
it's very hard right it's very hard not
to be in the mindset of
where the snipers right
um
also presumably hard to
care about things like which brand of
milk you buy right it's just very
distorting because for one thing you
mean and actually this goes a little bit
to i think what you were experiencing
out in the world today and what i saw a
lot of when i was traveling last week
but there's something about watching
the other humans
not quite aware of some aspect that you
think you see and it's it's very
disorienting yeah we didn't talk about
that uh earlier did we but i i came home
from having gone to a farmers market and
then just walked around a little bit
this morning and said it just it feels
like
this is what people maybe think they
were looking like three years ago before
covert ever hit but it doesn't it
doesn't feel right it feels like people
are
sort of reverted to a slightly angry
slightly
tribal
slightly mean-spirited way of engaging
with one another
and yet it also feels even more fragile
than it did before and one of the things
that i have
that i've always done
whenever i travel but especially in the
non-developed world uh is
smile at strangers and you know there's
there's contexts in which this is not
necessarily advised and of course a
woman alone doing this is a different
situation than a one with other people
or a man doing it but um it is
almost all the time that i have done
this it has been met with a smile in
return it immediately makes
you know it just creates a bond that is
fleeting because then you walk past one
another but you just interchange
something real with another human being
and convey to them
hey i'm here too you're there i see you
i don't hate you right and the way that
people are walking around right now is
just so full of glower so full of
meanness and
um
[Music]
already
it feels like it's harder to get people
to smile
well i think
they are
in some sense suffering you know rachel
maddow has
done much wrong including slander us but
um
she did us a favor
revealing her own anguish
at the moment when
they were told wrongly it turned out
that vaccinated folks weren't going to
have to wear their masks
and she you know wrestled on camera with
the idea oh my god the good people are
going to be the ones without the masks
that's going to be weird which snatches
do we trust right exactly yeah and so i
guess what i'm imagining is at the
moment
you don't have a reliable indicator of
what team other people are on do ya and
you know that at any moment the team
thing could come back and the point is i
think people are looking around with a
certain amount of suspicion yeah and
what if i smile back at that person and
she turns out to be a nazi right exactly
yeah exactly um so anyway the fact that
you know the thing has done such a good
job of demonizing your fellow citizens
and now you think they're out there but
you know they're no longer doing you the
service of you know calling attention to
themselves by wearing their masks or
whatever
is bound to increase that so anyway
childhood trauma ptsd healing and
recovery
so ptsd is like the mind which can
mature into a new
reality but has a hard time
unlearning the lesson of that maturing
and that trips a lot of people up i know
there are a couple kinds of ptsd and
that this is only one of them i'm
describing but i think it's the classic
one
the other thing that i would say is
trauma
is the analogy between
a physical injury and a mental injury is
actually a pretty good analogy right
it's pretty robust and i would say
the thing that i don't hear said
is there's a difference between a wound
and a scar and neither of them is great
but you definitely want as quickly as
possible to take that wound and scar
over the scar is the thing that lets you
move on you may move on with a limp
but the point is it is not an ongoing
vulnerability and
at all costs what you don't want to do
is act in such a way that keeps your
wound open which is a lot of people's
instinct because the wound garners
sympathy and
you know it you you learn how to live
with it and maybe the point is you
become addicted to it yeah you get
addicted to the sympathy to the victim
status and even if that's not the case
even if you are really trying to be
honorable and and do the right thing and
you want to heal on all this the fact is
that as you are healing and we're
talking mostly metaphorically here but
this is true for physical wounds as well
in the healing process from something
deeply traumatic
there is a relatively long period during
which you are still wrestling you are
not yet
the self that you will become you are
not as as strong as you were and you are
not yet as strong as you will become you
are still actively healing in there for
some part of you is going into actively
making yourself better
excuse me but it's not visible still
yeah and so keeping that badge
visible keeping the wound visible so
that you have the flag on you so that
you don't have to constantly be
explaining oh my god i'm actually still
wrestling with this thing i'm sorry i'm
slow i'm sorry i'm like whatever it is
um you can you can point to a thing
without having to feel like you're
justifying it this is the wrong instinct
but it is hard it is hard to go through
that you know it can be depending on the
type of
injury we're talking about
you know
weeks once years decades
of actually i'm still
handicapped i'm i'm still i'm still
working with
this additional effort that i have to
put into getting better and that's not
visible and um and it almost it can feel
like a deception
to to put forward the like nope i'm good
yeah and yet the and yet that is almost
always going to be a more effective way
of moving through the world than trying
to keep uh the visible sign of injury
uh alive yeah it's just it can't help
but be a mistake because the
vulnerability that flows from having the
wound open is
is uh is a hazard um
i want to pick up on the
thing you said about the
uh months years decades
this is something i've actually noticed
about physical healing that i when i bet
dollars to doughnuts that it
fits the psychological healing as well
and i think i've experienced it
which is
there are wounds there are injuries
where you heal in some sort of primary
way right and then if you pay attention
right like so i had a surgery on my knee
i had my acl repaired after a uh
ultimate uh frisbee injury after a dude
dove into your knee
yep dove into my knee busted my acl
didn't even say he was sorry but did he
catch the disc
remember actually who was who's catching
the disc i've now forgotten i used to
have this vividly in mind and i've now
forgotten but um anyway i don't remember
but
um
the point is
busted my acl
that's a wound
i then had surgery to repair it
more wound
i then healed but there was a lot of
ways in which that leg
wasn't quite
up to snuff and one thing in particular
which was
my whole knee was numb i couldn't feel
them so it was very uncomfortable if i
kneeled down to do something the two
knees felt so different that it was just
really disorienting um now i couldn't
tell you which knee it was for sure i
can figure it out right if i feel around
a minute
it's that one it's my left but
but the point is the trajectory you know
there was a
one-year trajectory there was a
five-year trajectory and then there was
a long-term trajectory and you know only
the long-term one really involved my
being essentially back where i was yeah
now i've had obviously a number of
incidents like this and i'm recalling
you know maybe maybe it's of no interest
here but i'm recalling
a boat accident on march 30th of 2016.
uh
you know acute you know life-threatening
and um
you know extraordinary in every regard
threatening you know pain
pain and injury
and there were a number of acute
recoveries and you know the actual the
actual physical wounds healed and you
know even some of the soft tissue which
i would told and never was told would
never heal without surgery did heal and
then there were more things discovered
that i didn't get care for and i found a
number of people to care for various
things and i'm still not a hundred
percent of course
um but
i actually spent
this would have been
almost three years later like february
january february of 2019
i went and spent like many many hours
over the course of two days at this
korean women's spa
in tacoma washington which has
these far infrared rooms and steam
saunas and the hot plunge and the cold
plunge and you're just so so much
basically sauna
and
i was driving home in the rain it was
dark it was raining driving back home to
portland
and i was actually on
uh the phone with my oldest dearest
friend talking to her and at first i
thought it was because i was talking to
her and then i realized this is the
first time in almost three years that i
haven't actively been in pain
and i had
stopped actively noticing that there was
always pain and that's interesting yeah
it's like uh when you're in a noisy
environment but it's really like noise
and then it turns off and it's like
wow i didn't even realize there was
noise yeah i had accommodated i had
acclimated
and um
you know some some of that pain still
comes back sometimes but you know the
the background level of like nope that's
just going to be with you and then
like step function off
wow yeah and so you know the
the degrees
the degrees of healing the fact that
some of them are slowly declining and
some of them really do act as these step
functions like you know an acute injury
is a step function in the other
direction
um but usually we don't imagine that the
human process is but sometimes it it too
can be even without like surgical
intervention yep and i would say that
this is one more
you know as if we needed one more but
it's one more of these reasons to be
very cautious about complex systems
right you know you intervene in a
complex system
you don't know how many things have been
delicately balanced you know if your
pain is really not useful to you if it's
not warning you about something then the
body may have caused you to lose
awareness of it and the last thing you
want to do is disrupt that and suddenly
be unable to ignore it right
um you know who knows what
for example
noises are being cancelled right you
know
i have tinnitus
from a busted eardrum
but most of the time i don't notice it
but anything that caused me not to be
able to ignore it would drive me crazy
right so it's uh
there's there's all sorts of stuff and
you have no idea how beautifully it's
functioning even when you're broken and
you know you've been thrashed by a boat
in your case right you have no idea how
many of those balances are being
maintained right um and you know in your
case
it's lucky that you got to this new
new place where actually something that
you had been um adaptively ignoring
uh was actually better enough that you
could you know slow down that circuit
yeah yeah
all right
the us versus them right versus left
reason versus woke etc thing doesn't
seem like it will ever resolve each side
only seems to buckle down more in their
views whatever the issue do we ever get
out of this
i mean this is such a tragedy because i
do think the way out of this is so
freaking easy but people are gonna have
to surrender some of their basic
assumptions that they're too in love
with right i mean you and i have
experienced this how glorious was it
to discover that all sorts of people
that we had been told were real living
demons just weren't that they were
decent people and we had some different
values and we had a lot of overlapping
values and we saw things differently but
there was room to talk and yeah um i
think that you know i used to say i
haven't said in a long time but
that to the extent that you have
bigotry
of any kind that you yourself and your
head have bigotry do you have bigotry
and i don't i don't mean inherently
racial bigotry just any kind of bigotry
any you know prejudgment that isn't
justified by actual facts all right
you can give yourself an effective raise
right like imagine you can just give
yourself a raise wouldn't you
well get rid of your goddamn bigotry
right if you get rid of your bigotry
it's like getting a raise because
suddenly you're not worried about people
who aren't actually
you know don't require your worry in
order for the stars on their bellies
right so anyway my point would be
to the extent that
both sides appear to be
out of their gourds
that they both believe people on the
other side
are possessed of the deepest
characterological flaws right you know
when it comes to the politicians
they're probably right when it comes to
the rest of us what are the chances
right what are the chances people are
basically the same they want basically
the same stuff to the extent that people
seem
so mysterious in their beliefs and
desires that they don't even deserve
human compassion that's somebody's
somebody has lied to you and made you
feel this that's not the way people are
for the most part so no it's active
dehumanization and you should wonder who
who wins by you having that in your head
about other humans that's the key
question who
wins by you believing that and therefore
what do you i mean i used to
do this almost as a i don't want to
trivialize it but almost as a game right
there are lots of bridges you're not
supposed to be able to cross
it's interesting to figure out how many
of them you can cross and what you have
to say to you know
to get an embrace on the other side and
anyway you know idw
was an experiment in exactly this
and
but i mean you used to do it
i here in portland it's never happened
but um
in olympia and in ann arbor um the two
places we lived prior to here
we would occasionally have jehovah's
witnesses show up at the door
and um
you unlike i
have to imagine almost everyone else
they ever had opened the door would
invite them in yep and talk to them and
um offered to exchange literature and so
you would offer the selfish gene to them
in exchange for you taking their
literature and suggest that they come
back after a while with the promise that
you had looked at some of what uh they'd
given you and if they had also looked at
some of what you had given them and i
don't know if any of them ever came back
they did they did they did no i had
repeat conversations interestingly it
was easier with the jehovah's witnesses
than mormons i don't know why but
um maybe because the mormons tend to be
younger and
they were on their like
constrained work like this is their
their
there's a name for it i can't remember
at the moment yeah
service whatever they're doing but um
but
you know look if you let a jehovah's i
mean first of all
i never did this under false pretenses i
would always say look you got your work
cut out for you you're talking to an
evolutionary biologist and i know what
it is that we disagree on however
there's an awful lot we might agree on
um
but if you let them know
right that you know that jehovah's
witnesses were persecuted by the nazis
right it warms their heart to discover
that anybody remembers that feature of
history right it gets forgotten they
hear all about the holocaust and nobody
remembers that they were on on the
losing side of
that horrible chapter so anyway there's
lots of ways in um and i swear it is the
most interesting
in terms of a skill that pays back in in
terms of warm feelings about humanity
that skill just being able to figure out
how you're going to talk to somebody who
is not
similar to you
is it's a total winner and
anyway so the answer to your question is
i think that this exists out there for
us at any time we want to figure out how
to avail ourselves of it and the problem
is we have to shut down the people who
know that they will lose if we start
seeing eye to eye
right if we start paying attention to
what the hidden tribes report
described as the exhausted middle this
vast group of people who mostly agree on
where we should be headed and what that
should look like who can't find each
other because we've been told that the
other half of that vast exhausted middle
is actually demons
right
so it's there we just have to figure out
how to do it so let's i'm reminded i
can't remember now it's been long enough
since
we were at evergreen that i don't
remember the framing but there was like
five foci and six expectations right and
i don't remember
and they were vulnerable they were good
and one of them in one of these lists
you know five fosimon of green education
six expectations of an evergreen
graduate something something
one of them was it was either teaching
or reaching
across significant differences
and
i remember thinking for a long time but
especially as of may 23 2017 and beyond
almost no one here seems to be trying to
do this
um there is an awful lot of we have the
truth and we are the only arbiters and
owners of the truth and all who disagree
with us shall be shut down permanently
but this actually reaching across
significant differences extending a hand
in friendship in openness in
let me share with you anything
is
of course has to be the way forward yep
next question
i bought douglas murray's book the war
in the west he labels the enemy as
marxists others say communists or
technocratic fascists and so on it's
hard to fight an enemy that has no name
yeah
that's it that's the question um
this is true
there are certainly elements of what we
face that are familiar i mean you know
for example we talked in the main
podcast about
the fact that public private partnership
is uh
you don't have to squint at it very hard
to see the relationship to fascism on
the other hand
i think fascism in general comes
from
government right kicking the private
sector into agreement
um and moving forward um but in this
case
it's the reverse now somebody will
probably correct me historically and
they'll say no it's always the corporate
side that drives it
i'll be interested to discover that but
nonetheless you can have differences
right are these marxists yeah
they appear to be they've got some
differences right
even marxists agree that uh we have
differential
contributions to make and these uh
radical
neo-marxist types appear to believe that
all appearances of differences in
capacity are the result of some jedi
mind trick from the dark side or i don't
know what but
and yet some of the founders of blm um
acknowledge that they are trained as and
working in the sort of image of marxism
right yeah i mean look you know it
depends how how much precision you need
right if you don't need that much
precision then yes they're in that very
ballpark and the flaws are the very same
and
um we don't have to worry too much about
it yeah i mean i guess i feel like
there is
there is an empty niche for someone to
actually try to carefully build the
taxonomy
in which you know maybe it's a venn
diagram other than a taxonomy of like
actually of all of these terms
um how how much overlap is there and
to what degree is there meaningful
distinction between them and to what
degree are we is is the understanding of
what we are
working with in society enhanced by
drilling down on those differences
okay i agree i also think as always
that
these questions have an evolutionary
dimension that is never included and so
if we take you know
i would say communism is evolutionarily
unstable right that's why it goes
through the
pattern that you know tends to um
you know end with uh
starvation i thought it had just never
been done right yeah i've heard that um
but here's the thing well what about
china seems pretty durable
yeah but how communist is it right it
seems to have sort of pruned the
communism away from the authoritarianism
and the authoritarianism actually works
pretty good and you know frankly it's
capitalist facing outwards and it's
authoritarian facing inwards and it is
you know phenomenally
yeah nominally marxist but yeah you know
it's found a formula which i'm afraid
is a very functional formula for getting
into the future my nose
marxist is a name only
yeah i like it
i like it i like that a lot
all right um
what do you make of the sudden outbreak
of hepatitis and children that test
positive for adenovirus are anti-vaxxers
seeing turtles and clouds or could there
be a relationship to the adenovirus
vector vaccines yeah i i think
it is very likely that this is related
to the adenovirus vaccines it is not
certain it could be a coincidence there
are certainly lots of adenoviruses that
circulate
um
but well i also i guess i don't know in
the u.s anyway uh there's only one
adenovirus vectored vaccine that is
available at all and i don't think it's
authorized for children at all
so j j isn't available to children right
i'm not sure that that's what we're
seeing here right in other words i i i
agree but this this
the way this is phrased sounds like uh
sounds like this is about kids who've
gotten adenovirus vaccines that are now
uh and so like i don't i don't that
doesn't seem to me to be a plausible
mechanism at least in those countries i
don't know
like if in other places jnj or
astrazeneca is authorized for children i
don't think so but i don't remember i
don't think that's what's most likely
okay i think it is more likely that
we engineered an adenovector
and that adenovector has interacted with
wild adenoviruses in some way a
recombination event or something like it
and therefore that we have effectively
you know
this welcome to complex systems lesson
is a tough one for people but uh but the
point is look you intervened in
a complex system
and frankly i didn't see this one coming
but um
but part of that system is
there is an ecology of adenoviruses out
there and you are introducing something
that you've built for a purpose but it
interacts with those others in some way
now i don't know
how readily they recombine yeah for me
there's just like there's enough black
boxes there it's like okay how really
they you know how readily the lab type
is going to recombine with the wild type
and then get out of you know get out
into the world and then infect a child
like there's a whole there's a whole lot
of
right but but i guess the point is
uncertainty
all you need
is an evolutionarily stable strategy or
something somewhat better um
to
you know it only needs to
encounter the opportunity
for the
uh combination of characteristics
once and then the point is if it is an
effective
uh union of those things
then
it will do what it's going to do so
very hard to track down
yep and again if i've got something
wrong here i'd be very curious to hear
what it is
indeed uh
love the show been listening for a while
i've been wondering if you are aware of
the work of alan savory and his book
holistic management
i am not
i am not
is male female pair bonding truly the
best way to raise kids or is it only
best because you've structured society
around such pairings for historical
reasons
shouldn't the priority be ensuring that
you have loving role models
yes and yes
yeah right um
the priority should be ensuring that you
have loving role models for sure
and
um
if you have one loving role model that
is certainly better than zero and if you
have
five loving role models who actually
have your best interests at heart
and
they're all male or all female that's
terrific
it's much harder to maintain stability
at the social level or stability at the
financial level when you have a lot or
or only one respectively
and
um there is we've talked about this
before
i think
at least one
potential advantage to having
a male and a female role model over
having two male versus two or two female
role models which is just
that every child grows up in the world
um trans rights activists
notwithstanding with all of the [ __ ]
that they are proclaiming about what sex
is in which there are two sexes and
there are men and there are women and so
having at least you know one person in
your world who is an adult who is of
each of the two sexes
is very useful as you develop your model
of the world so um if you know if you
are growing up with two dads or if
you're growing up with two moms it would
be very useful for those two dads to
have at least one
female friend around who was present
enough for your kid for the kid to you
know see what it's like to be an adult
woman and of course the opposite applies
if you're two moms to have an adult man
around
so i would add another value to the
traditional male female couple
which is it also models the kind of
relationship that the child is most
likely to have right chances are a
child's straight
then having a model of that relationship
is also valuable in addition to just
having a model of what an adult man and
adult woman are like
but i would say look there's bound to be
a
hierarchy of
um
good
structure sorry it's cold it's getting
good structures for parenting right
a
highly functional
male female couple
has those two advantages that we've just
described right it's probably best
all else being equal and that's the key
all else being equal is probably best
for those two reasons
a dysfunctional heterosexual couple is
probably inferior to
a gay couple that's got their [ __ ]
together for sure or all of the other
functional things well
you know then there's a question about
how a couple versus a single parent
right a single parent is hobbled by the
fact that they don't have
you know that they're stretched really
thin almost no matter what they do
stretch really thin but able to provide
consistency as opposed to a really
dysfunctional couple either straight or
gay
that is sending very distinct and
opposing um feedback into the kid's head
is going to you know perhaps make that
kid anti-fragile but certainly not help
them develop a you know coherent sense
of what makes sense in the universe if
their two parents regardless of what
sexes they are um are effectively
fighting at each other through the child
yep
um so you know a
uh
well-adjusted highly functional single
parent probably better than a fighting
couple so anyway you know you could list
all of these things and you know
actually
the heterosexual couple ain't the top of
that heap either right we've got several
versions of like an isolated
heterosexual couple compared to any
other structure that's embedded in
uh some sort of functional community
right where their grandparents around
cousins etc so
i don't know what this looks like we're
just doing this on the fly
but you could probably figure out you
know big font at the very top it should
say all else being equal because that's
the key thing but all else being equal
you could probably do the hierarchy of
which of these things is likely to be
best for the kid you know and at the
bottom of it you would have um you know
no parents right foster care or worse
right
but anyway something like that
how do you make someone think they seem
scared of everything including thinking
i don't know who the they is there but
it's
it could be a lot of people
yeah this is what we used to specialize
in i guess we still specialize in it but
the techniques are different yeah when
we actually knew the people yeah in the
classroom i would say
what you mean by think
is not the
under the surface i'm unaware of why i
have this intuition about that thing
what you mean by think presumably is the
conscious cognitive
process and the way you get somebody to
do that
is you cause their mind not to be able
to easily categorize something or
reconcile it in other words the
conscious mind is there to process
phenomena that can't be dealt with on
autopilot and so the answer to how you
get them to think is you deliver things
to them
that they know that they can't answer
quickly and that force them in order you
know not to have you know be in the
uncomfortable situation of not knowing
what to say or whatever
to grapple with the question anew so i
used to call this throwing errors you
want to get their mind to throw errors
and if you can get them to throw an
error you know it can be a joke
it can be a riddle right it can be a
paradox but anything that causes the
mind to hiccup and say wait
you know
anything like that will do the trick
yeah
no for sure and i think this is one of
the places where social media completely
fails us um because not having any
accountability being you can't you can't
get anyone to come to account um if they
have time to um if they can just walk
away and you know they they feel no
embarrassment about like i don't know
how to respond to that they can just
yell at you in response
yep that's true yeah actually you're
right social media
by virtue of the asynchronousness of it
and by virtue of the way it um frees you
you know it's awkward interpersonally if
you're sitting with somebody and they
pose a question to you and you really
don't know the answer to it and you
pretend you do or you don't say anything
those are all you know the social
pressure will cause you to react but
yeah
not so on twitter yeah
um this question
okay it's not it's not at the top of the
list but it came in twice so i'm gonna
ask it but i don't actually have no idea
who he's referring to
he i don't know it says hello bretton
heather reconsider your previous support
of a certain individual
and i don't know what
i i don't know
if it's if they're talking about someone
political or i honestly have no idea
what's referring to myself
that's a reference so if you want to
write in again and say who you're
talking about um we'll answer the
question
yeah
something transpired that we don't know
well it came in twice at different
moments so um
okay next question
is it not possible that the argument
that psych meds cause violence is
misattributing violence to medications
when it is likely the case that troubled
individuals are more likely to be
prescribed those drugs in the first
place
broken people use more meds but
generally meds aren't what broke them
i think it is true uh
that broken people use more meds and
therefore you cannot simply uh see that
um broken people and meds go together
and therefore claim that the meds are
what broken them because
presumably
mostly people are not prescribed meds
unless there is something to prompt that
in the first place but
um
look at the book
anatomy of an epidemic i think is what
it's called
by whitaker
and uh and look at the evidence that he
compiles about what is actually
happening with regard to many of these
psychotropic
medications that are being prescribed to
people and how and how ruined it makes
them and i'm not talking about violence
specifically here i think that is that
is a subcategory about which i know less
but there is ample evidence that many of
the prescription drugs that we have been
prescribing to people
in order to quote unquote help with
mental health are actually promoting and
in large measure causing the mental
health crisis that we now find ourselves
in yeah i will say the evidence on
violence is actually better than you're
imagining you're imagining them to lose
correlation and actually these things
have been studied more
in a more rigorous way than you're
thinking
so
do take a look
at chris martinson's podcast from
yesterday
in particular
drill down on
there's a paper uh in
public library of science
in which the particular compounds in
question are analyzed and you can see
which types of drugs it is
so chris martinson who is himself as a
phd in toxicology
does this yesterday he's he's in exactly
honesty
and the evidence is
pretty compelling including some stuff
that uh
does separate out the effect you're
talking about like people who have never
had these violent thoughts who suddenly
upon being put on these drugs do have
them and then can't shake them for days
to months yeah okay so yeah
yeah so there is something going on and
it's uh um it's more than just a
correlation
um
i think says a guy named tom i think
that nina jankowicz was the stay puft
marshmallow man from ghostbusters the
destroyer in ludicrous form
yeah yeah nina janowitz who was the uh
now dethroned minister of mystics or
male information i don't even know what
her supposed title was but uh she
probably ought not to put out that video
singing as if she was mary poppins
um but better for all the rest of us
that she did yes but even the uh the
exit
you know the headline on the article
primary article that reported on this
was like
um
you know
disinformation board
um
sunk by by disinformation by right-wing
trolls or something right and so you
know the article itself is
disinformation right you know what we
need right now is a disinformation oh
what we need is to take two mirrors and
put them right opposite each other right
and then we need to see if they blow
each other up with the information put a
speaker and a microphone right across
from each other and we'll feed them
yeah
it's incredible it is incredible indeed
microplastics
coming up
fine microplastics are the areas
microplastics are they a major issue for
us can evolution handle it what can we
do to protect ourselves and a society
about this
yes they're a major issue for us um
evolution's never seen anything like it
before
and
uh it is not clear what
what our way out is well i think it is
sort of clear which is yeah i mean
it's not clear how we get there there is
no getting there but you got to stop
making this stuff in a way that ends up
in the environment right either you need
some sort of a closed cycle where every
time you manufacture some of this stuff
its end point where it gets recovered
safely is known
or
you need to stop making it all together
and then the world will stop grinding it
up into tiny little fragments and
distributing it where we breathe it in
and eat it and all the other things that
happen
it will eventually exhaust itself now
there's a huge amount of it out there
it's not going to happen quickly
but the key thing would be you know this
is the truth for so many of the major
issues right you've got an issue of what
to do about the people who
you know
have autism right or are you know
need orthodontia or any of these things
right these are good questions but a
better question is hey let's figure out
what to do about those people let's also
figure out what's causing this so that
we can stop it yes right stopping
creating more people who are in the
situation that you can't quite figure
out what to do about is always a good
idea indeed
okay
um
how is it
that social media algorithms will flag
anything related to code 19 but they
can't flag a crazy 18 year old in texas
that's a very interesting question
um it does feel like
um although asking for algorithms to
flag
individuals is a slippery slope
uh we clearly
have the technological chops for a lot
of things that we're not doing
yes and in each of these cases
where
you have somebody go off the rails
there's more than just sort of social
media stuff right
your friends and this yeah right i mean
this you know the killer in uvalde um
you know
cut his own face up
right
yeah he cut his own face up um
you know for kicks apparently right
that's a pretty unusual behavior you
don't say um yeah i do say yeah
um and you know there were there were
other
flags and
you know the
i mean there is always the issue just
like you were talking about with regard
to the police like you know you
you don't want a lot of people who are
going through something and are just
fine to be hassled by the authorities
and you also don't want to have the
people who are going through something
and aren't going to be just fine to not
be hassled and there are going to be
errors and which set of errors does
society prefer to make
right but then there's also this
difficult issue here which is
background checks do
ask you about
mental disorders
a young person 18 year old
birthday has had less time for such
things to show up in the system but to
the extent that they have you might put
a higher priority on it
and then
this
also raises the question yes many people
have noticed that almost all of these
mass shootings yeah
involve men
below the age of 25 right okay and many
people have suggested maybe your right
to bear arms shouldn't begin until 25.
now i don't think constitutionally you
can do that without major surgery yes
but
it does i mean a there is this question
right
as you know i'm in the process of trying
to get a motorcycle license it's
approximately 70 times harder than even
getting a concealed carry permit right
the
degree of
scrutiny by the state
is
very small for guns and
rightly substantial for for a motorcycle
um not rightly greater for a motorcycle
but rightly substantial rightly
substantial right they don't want you
operating a motorcycle even though
you're primarily a danger to yourself
yeah but you put you you put other
people at risk of killing you if you're
incompetent in a way that you don't if
you're you put you put other people at
less risk of killing you if you're
incompetent if you're in a car right and
um a motorcyclist can cause a car
accident that would put other people in
data but
nonetheless the point is
there should be
we should be able to agree
that
your right
to have a firearm
does not necessarily mean your right to
easy access where somebody who does not
have the proper parallel
characterological characteristics um can
get one and then haul off and kill a
bunch of people you should be put
through a you know a course where you
actually demonstrate that you know how
to
how to treat this object safely and
and the like so
we could
a there's the question of what we can do
about the age issue
how the second amendment is interpreted
in light of the fact
that uh you have protected rights that
maybe
a sober person would recognize
um shouldn't kick in until you're 25 or
kick in in a limited way yes um
no i mean i
i mean and this is this is another thing
that the insanity insane discussion
around
that's supposedly around trans rights is
actively obscuring
young men
are the people who are who are the most
likely to be violent in society yeah
across every domain
and you know claiming now that there are
you know women raping people and like
like okay yes that very occasionally can
happen somehow but like for god's sake
why would we confuse this issue right
why would we actively choose to become
confused about something that every
society throughout history has known and
no it's not misandrious to identity that
nor is it transphobic to say that it's
simply true and we can honor amazing
masculinity and also say and that toxic
[ __ ] you're doing no
no no 100 yeah
uh thoughts oh wait there was there were
another you're not going to say prayers
no i'm not i'm gonna go to that one
after but there was another
uh gunish one
oh a couple
um
guns
this is written with a few words missing
i think
how about guns
21 years old to have access to like
alcohol except for military personnel so
that's sort of just in keeping with what
you had said 25
21
um you know increasing the age i don't
know i don't think the bill of rights
specifies an age
no it doesn't but the problem is
it's not specifying an age probably
protects you
your right to have them
from 18 because you know
why
why wouldn't the gun control folks then
just set the age you know 103.
um well i mean i i don't
i don't know anything about this history
or this law
but i don't know on what basis uh the
the legal age to drink is variable by
states and on what basis that has been
decided and why for instance
uh apparently if you're in the military
you can drink if you're under 21
even in states where it's 21. well i
don't know anything about that but i
would say you know
there is no
constitutional right to drink and so
that's why
this is a problem
but at a practical level on the other
but there's a constitutional right to
bear arms
you know well-regulated militia et
cetera et cetera but then why 18. right
like you know we're establishing some
boundary
so again like i have no idea
you can own them you can't buy them well
i don't know i don't know enough i don't
know enough about it okay but uh yeah i
will say i think you get into if you if
you decide well there's no
constitutional you know right at 18 then
of course you just stepped on the
slippery slope yep yep
um and here's i'll come back
um
yeah here are a couple of more guns
questions and there are only a few
questions left so i'll try to get to all
of them
in canada we have cool-off periods
licenses and background checks for guns
thoughts
well we have background checks yeah and
we have licenses
for some we have background checks and
then we have licenses for certain things
like suppressors
yeah um um we do not
i don't think have cool off periods
well there no yeah
you know look i can only talk about
oregon because i've seen it
in oregon
if you're and this is going to be widely
variable by state yes yeah but all
states have background checks yes all
states have that that's federally
mandated yeah
um
the
if in oregon
well especially if you have a concealed
carry permit that is effectively like
tsa pre
for gun purchases you've gone through
some scrutiny ahead of time once you
have your concealed carry it becomes
easier to buy future guns you the
chances so when you buy a gun
whether you buy it online and it gets
delivered to what's called an ffl which
is a licensed
gun dealer so you cannot if you buy a
gun online they don't send it to you
right and what what is a gun
is carefully defined there's some part
of a gun that is essential you can buy
the other parts without a problem but
the part that is deemed the gun
has a number
and it is delivered if you order it or
if you buy it in a shop
the ffl then runs the background check
so they're trained to run the background
check they submit your name to a
computerized system and then it either
comes back you passed or
you're in the queue if you're in the
queue they send you home and then they
give you a call when you pass or
presumably if you don't pass they give
you a call and say you didn't pass and
they send it back to
wherever it came from
and you know if you buy a gun from an
individual they will have to send it to
an ffl also they can't just hand it off
to you right now there is
something that i remember from days of
old some loophole gun shows don't know
never been
no idea what that is but um but in
general everything goes through this
bottleneck of these people with a
special license to
give you a a controlled firearm
um
none of that sounds like a cool-off
period well but that's the point is if
your background check does not get
passed immediately
then you're effectively it's effectively
a cool off period right yeah it may i
mean
for some people it may act as quite the
opposite
and raging period
yeah i mean i think
everybody's used to it
um and you know the fact is oddly the
concealed carry permit isn't that hard
to get so people who are interested in
buying multiple guns will typically just
do that and then they will speed to the
front of the cube but presumably if
there was something in their
background that was alarming so
the
some states oregon
is what's called a will issue state
which means that although the thing i
think goes to the sheriff in the county
that you um
you apply
the sheriff will give you a concealed
carry permit unless there's a good
reason not to in other words the
presumption is if you apply and you pass
the
course you'll get it
um
and then if there's some reason like you
know you lied about
having committed a felony or something i
would hope right yeah then you won't get
it um
but again it's it's the tsa pre-model
right it's the scrutiny has been done
ahead of time and that's why you skipped
to the head of the queue at the point
it's not that it's not that you can skip
the scrutiny but you've you've paid a
little extra you've taken yeah and you
yeah you've thought about it in advance
and then like okay this is worth this is
worth my time to have been vetted yes
and effectively be in the system and
like okay like i've given up a little
bit of my privacy here so that
um so that i have this
privilege that is not and that's why i i
it wasn't that i was missing the word
it's like it's a privilege it's not a
right it's not a right to skip to the
security line at the airport it's not a
right right to um
not have your background looked into
when you want to purchase a gun it's
it's a a privilege to
um have your background looked into and
then have basically you know stamped on
the forehead with like you're good to go
yeah um
as with tsa pre though it involves you
submitting your fingerprints right so
when you get out that's why i say you
you you hand over some part of your
privacy right well you hand that over
if you don't have the license and you go
to buy a weapon they will fingerprint
you as part of the background check
right so your fingerprints make it into
the system but there's no chance i don't
know what they do with the fingerprints
at the point you get a concealed carry
license it's quite possible what they do
is they compare them to a list of
unsolved crimes where they have
fingerprints or something
and
well and or you know
any time you've said here are my
fingerprints the government right
my sense is i have to presume that those
fingerprints of mine now exist in some
potential federal database oh absolutely
like i don't presume that they have
destroyed them right no no no i don't
like that fact but i you know you ha you
have to assume if you have said
okay in order to make my life
better as i value it with regard to
going through airports or owning a gun i
am going to hand you this bit of my
privacy with which you can identify me
in the future should i should i choose
to do something heinous okay
in that case but i think your point is
even if you didn't do something heinous
they can still identify you right by by
these biometric uh measures but right
anyway it is what it is now all of this
raises as long as we're here yeah the uh
interesting and rather complex question
of what is now being called ghost guns
in yet another
phase of our
collective catastrophe i've never heard
that term i don't know what that means
so here's the problem
i've told you about
the ffl that is necessary in order for
you to buy a gun right now you have to
define gun
right
now the problem is let's say
it's very clintonian well i mean look
this is the problem with the law is that
the law sure
if i say look in order to buy a gun you
know you need to pass a background check
and then
you say well
what's a gun
and you say well it's the part of the
gun that does x y and z
and
you know
well let's suppose that you're going to
make that part of a gun right like the
lower of a of a
an ar
gun right let's say you're going to make
that out of a block of metal
that block of metal will become one of
those but it isn't one yet right so the
question is how close
an individual can't fabricate that with
hand tools right you know like a cnc or
that's something right right and so
there is
some group of people that have actually
started this as a business which is they
will sell you
a piece that is below the threshold
where it is not yet a gun
and they will send sell you the machine
with the program that will turn it into
a gun
right and now you can see how difficult
it is to regulate this because the
answer is it kind of reminds me of the
mrna vaccines actually a little bit
yeah actually yeah you're gonna it's
like yeah
i see the analogy much like a sense of
like you know there's no antigen in this
thing we're going to make your cell
produce the thing you go ahead and make
that for yourself right yeah exactly
so anyway it's a very interesting thing
and
you know there is a question of like oh
well come on okay that is a gun um on
the other hand at some point it isn't
one and so however you far you chase the
threshold back right there's some point
at where it isn't yeah and you know is
it illegal to exchange
you know
the shape of a gun in a cad program
right if you source the billet yourself
and all you have is a computer program
that describes what a gun is like isn't
that something that requires you know so
it's very hard to regulate right sure um
and there's a question about what to do
which is of course what so many of the
conservatives have been saying all along
to those of us who are like of course we
need good regulation on all of these
things they're like yes but you know the
devil's in the details how do you define
good like how do i get good stable
evolutionarily stable regulation
and in many cases it's damn impossible
well at least can we get rid of these
assault weapons well
define it right
right assault weapon basically means
rifle that you don't like the looks of
right you know yeah that that's you know
what are you gonna do about that right
right
so
yes it's a morass yeah yes um
um
one more gun comment guns aren't the
only tool for toppling tyrants trucks
and bouncy castles work too it's
especially the bouncy castle it's
especially the bouncy castles and that
was so amazing and unfortunately that
dude is still in power up in canada what
the hell
but
okay yes
that dude
whoever his father is
[Laughter]
um
the certain individual at this oh this
is the certain individual are you sorry
that you voted for the certain
individuals joe biden
lost lots of sup last month yeah i'm not
sorry i voted for him because i never
voted for him and neither did he why
neither of us assume that we voted for
him yeah never would never did didn't
vote for trump either but didn't vote
for biden never was going to no way no
clinton
uh you voted for him you voted for him
no i didn't bill no i didn't i did not
vote for bill yes you did i didn't i
voted for in 92 i didn't vote for i
didn't vote for him
i never voted for bill i mean i can't
say 100 but my recollection is i did not
vote for bill not even once i did vote
for obama once but not twice
we will i will not i will not press this
button well if you're right you're right
but uh that is not my recollection in
any case if i did vote for bill then yes
i am sorry
we have said uh
we'll do this off there maybe come back
but all right i
i believe i have the receipts on this
um wow
all right if you got him you got him i
then i then i owe an apology because i
think voting for bill is a terrible
thing i think bill is the place that the
democratic party
became
something other than the representative
of working people for sure and i did uh
once i did not vote for him in 96 but um
uh
but we'll we'll come back to that maybe
um the pro-gun argument in one line
predators don't like armed prey
well yeah yes that's a and argument on
the other hand
i
frankly
to gun rights folks i think
you just have to acknowledge
that although it is not the only
contributing
factor easy access to guns is one of the
things
that makes these massacres
possible they would not be
common otherwise and it may be one of
three or four such contributing factors
and it may be the one that we can't
afford because of the downs side of not
having
um self-protection as we discussed and
the ability to fend off tyranny should
it come
but
anyway i think it is a i think it is
self-evident that the easy access to
guns in the us is
um
making
this environment
extremely dangerous and
but that is worth acknowledging
indeed okay so we are trying to just get
to these last couple of questions a
couple more just came in
but we only had four left i'll see
quickly
does the following line resonate with
you i'm a conservative of liberal values
i don't think so no no no i'm not i'm
not sure what it means it fits with what
we've said
but i don't know what what it helps
conservatives um
protect the gains of past liberals
right
liberals are the ones who innovate these
things and then conservatives defend
them but almost all the conservatives
that i end up hearing from or talking to
say um
of course
most of them many of them now not most
of them maybe but many of the ones who i
talk to say that they have liberal
values but they say i'm like i'm a
conservative
so
i'm not sure this this doesn't feel
i don't know this just doesn't feel
right to me
well i mean look i think
the whole thing comes down to how
driven to change are you right
liberals
are inclined to try to solve problems
conservatives are very sensitive to the
unintended consequences of problem
solving they are not necessarily and in
general are not hostile to problems that
have been solved remaining solved right
so
it is you know it is a tension between
two things and
even at this moment let's say you have
conservatives trying to conserve all
kinds of things that we all agreed on
until five minutes ago but those things
are actually the product of a liberalism
of the west right yeah but they're also
increasingly a product of the hyper
novelty which is everyone's fault
like we have we've all been running
palmell into you know more and more
rapid change you know even
like the amish aside
everyone's got a damn phone yep um that
they are addicted to pretty much right
so you could talk all you want about you
know wanting to preserve certain values
and be accepting a lot of very crazy
very rapidly changing so-called progress
on a lot of fronts
and um
saying that you are you know saying that
you are in favor of cons of pre-existing
of already solved
problems staying solved right now
imagines that we are living in a static
world and we are living in the opposite
of aesthetic oh no so that's that's why
i'm objecting to i don't i don't know
what you're objecting to you and i have
made the point
we can't do that we can't afford
conservatism at the moment because we
can't stay here there's nothing to
conserve right that ship has sailed we
are now in a situation
where yes there are a lot of values that
need to be protected right that is maybe
inherently the role of conservatives to
make sure we don't lose track of who we
are and what we believe in and all of
that but we have to architect new we
have to negotiate things anew because we
simply aren't anywhere stable yeah um so
yeah i totally agree with that but you
know i i didn't read that into the
question as okay as an issue
um
three oh well okay so
quick the person who asked about the
book holistic management by alan savory
wants to know if we take a look at it
from an evolutionary science perspective
um i've opened it in a tab that's all
i'm gonna say i'll tell you at the
moment i have no idea what kind of book
it is someone says citalopram made me
lose feeling over half my body for years
afterwards well butan made me violent
the carnivore diet fixed my major
depression so that's i i've
we were talking just yesterday about
some of the
uh incredible sensitivities that many
people we know have who have had to
solve them by putting themselves on
extreme elimination diets and then very
carefully bring a few things back
mostly nutrient dense real food you know
without you know not highly processed
still highly resembling the organism off
an animal that it came from
um which is different but related to
from and to
the question of whether or not the
fancy very comp molecularly complex
pharmaceuticals helped make them crazy
in the first place um is there any
chance that we should
um
confederate all those people with their
special diets and call them the
illuminati
yes okay good on it okay three last
questions
um what data is your mistrust of code
vaccines based on have you written about
this
um so so much we wrote about it a little
bit um a long time ago in uh on i think
it's like
it's july
the maybe first or second post on my sub
stack
uh which you'll find near the top if you
go to you know top things on natural
selections it's a very long piece it's
got its stuff on
vaccines it's stuff on early treatment
a lot of things on how it is that
data appear to be being manipulated and
why why at that point we were concerned
and of course there is
you know 10 more months worth of data
and analysis out there at this point and
no neither of us has written explicitly
more on it but there is a there is a lot
out there all right a couple things to
add one
i would suggest an upgrade to your
language
stop saying data you're much better off
with the word evidence right the problem
is data
divorced from a context doesn't mean
anything and so it's so frequently
abused so evidence is what you're
looking for
the evidence in the verse system in the
yellow card system in the military
system and incidentally there's a very
interesting i haven't had a chance to go
through it in detail but a very
interesting interview with matthew
crawford a friend of ours on what
appears to be anomalies in the military
adverse events recording system
uh well worth your time
but anyway there's tons of evidence
right there's tons of evidence and
there's also evidence that the system is
not at all interested in dealing with
the level of adverse events it's not
interested in dealing with people who
have these pathologies which is in and
of itself conspicuous right here's the
thing
vaccines
have side effects all drugs do right
that is not an argument against them
were it true that these vaccines were
safe enough right and effective enough
to deploy them this way then the system
would be very interested in dealing with
those small number of people for whom
the dice came up wrong
right those people did the right thing
they were injured
we should take care of them
the complete lack of interest in
acknowledging that these people have
even been injured much less figuring out
what to do about them is indicative of
the fact that they do not want us
knowing how many there are they would
much rather gaslight this huge number of
people that allow us to count them and
categorize their pathologies and figure
out what the pattern is right the fact
that the system is not interested in
these people tells you something is up
here right what kind of evidence is that
i'm not exactly sure but in conjunction
with the verse system and the yellow
card system and the military system
it's pretty clear that there's a problem
and uh
i would be shocked if any
objective person looked at
that evidence and came away with any
other conclusion
might plants hedge their bets producing
more potent pollen upon harassment
depends on what potent means but i've
written about a related hypothesis with
regard to
seed
uh
the maple seeds that are produced with
regard to the maples here in portland
uh feeling like they're much more they
produce much more urticating samaras
than the ones due up in olympia just 100
miles north uh the distinction that i
noticed that i hypothesize um being the
difference
is that uh portland is covered in
invasive english ivy uh whereas olympia
not so much
and then it really feels like in those
parts of portland that are particularly
coated in english ivy the samaras are
particularly urticating and difficult to
deal with um that being a certainly
labile enough characteristic to change
over um over the amount of time uh
required to sort of respond to english
ivy
potent hold on i want to come back to
your yeah
it is possible that something like that
could have occurred for example let's
say that the iv
causes the terrestrial rodent population
to go up and the terrestrial rodents eat
the samaras from maples so you could
then see that the ivy would cause an
increase in the seeds defending
themselves against being consumed by
rodents with this urticating stuff on
their surface something like that yeah
um okay you're gonna go on to the pollen
um
i'll just say here
zach if you want to just show my screen
for a second this was i guess back in
october
um on maple trees and tree frogs
protecting themselves this is um this is
where i talked about this explicitly
um
if i may have my screen back because i
don't remember what brett you think i
was gonna say oh just the question was
might plants hedge their bets producing
more potent pollen upon
harassment um
you know potent
meaning
what
like the idea that i i'm not sure yeah i
think i think the question isn't quite
right it's phrased into blunt away but i
would say
you would expect plants
to have
um
measures of parameters that mattered
right in other words
what ought to predict a plant producing
more pollen well if the recipient plants
are widely
spaced then producing more pollen might
be necessary in order to successfully
reproduce so a greater fraction of the
budget might be dedicated to it no
there's a question about how a tree
might know that and it could know that
from evolutionary history in other words
uh if it is in a very
sparsely divided forest you know if you
have a rare tree in a forest for example
then it is in a population in which that
species is rare and so producing more
pollen might simply be favored right you
could have things like that but you
could also have a responsive system that
would detect you know we we have plants
that do
that flower for example when they're
about to
die right as a last ditch effort to
convert what they've got into some kind
of reproduction right and so anyway you
could imagine all kinds of strategies
that would enhance the fitness of
plants and increasing pollen output in
response to some of them would be
natural right i mean maybe even
the wetness of the season right if your
pollen is going to get washed
into the stream and be useless then
maybe you need to produce more of it or
you need to you know
we're talking about uh wind pollination
or if you if you've got a vector a
pollinator i'm thinking about wind but
yeah right yeah i mean
all of these parameters change what what
exactly you predict um final question
for today do you have thoughts on the pc
rebranding of homeless to unhoused or
houseless
um yeah lots and
frankly and this is something we didn't
quite explicitly get to um in the first
in the first part of today's
stream uh this is something that
schellenberger talks a lot about in his
book san francisco san francisco i can't
even say it um
in which he and i don't remember exactly
one but he says basically that the term
homeless
was first was basically was moved in as
the way that we would now refer to this
population of people by
activists and proponents of the homeless
if you will
as a way to
to make them
seem
less other
and
furthermore what that then did was make
it seem like well the way that you solve
homelessness is to provide homes because
once you named a group based on one
thing that they don't have it would
appear that the solution is to rectify
the one thing that you don't have for
which the group has been named whereas
if you would call them um you know
people you know transients for instance
which sounds like homelessness but
actually it points to the lack of a
sense of place lack of a sense of home
lack of localness
there is a different set of issues and
of course if you talk about mentally ill
or drug addicted or any number of or you
know people who um are you know had one
major life event that that made meant
that they couldn't pay their their rent
uh that is you know again a different
kind of subclass of people who are now
largely calling homeless so this does
strike me as along the lines of
um
person of color people of color where
you know we the the naacp
uh is not a racist organization
right um but we are not now but it may
be now i don't know but the naacp the
national association for the advancement
of colored people
um uses the phrase colored people in its
name
which we are of course not allowed to
say anymore because somehow to say
colored person is racist but to say
person of color is not this feels
exactly like that it's a it's a way of
keeping people on their toes
and to change it up and to make sure
that you are it's it's fashion it's like
it's woke
um totalitarian fashion policing
uh no it's it's cryptic control yeah the
idea is you need the authoritarian part
yeah well okay
the point is you need to be up on what's
in and what's out and it's all art
that's the fashion part from with
respect to uh what's actually being said
and i think it was teacher mason the
special that we watched um makes the
point
that the terms that are now no longer
allowed are terms that were actually
used as euphemisms in order to you know
to
neutralize some kind of bigotry that was
real or imagined right and so yeah i
have no patience for this yeah the fact
is the unhoused right
the d house
right
the point is look
yes there are offensive terms for things
yes we shouldn't use those terms but we
should just figure out what the terms
are that are allow us to have a
conversation and we should shut the
authoritarians out of those
conversations so that the adults can
talk
if your primary contribution to a
conversation is oh don't say it that way
you probably don't have very much to add
yeah
yeah
yeah you should be allowed to say what
you want but in a conversation where
we're trying to figure out what to do
somebody who's not really interested in
that but is interested in
using it as an excuse for something
doesn't belong there indeed
all right well this has been long but uh
but it was a long time we were here two
days ago but before that it was a long
time and a lot of a lot of miles
traveled yep indeed
we will be back
in a week
same time same place like the terminator
i don't know how the terminator says
that i believe
we'll be back i see
we'll also be back here sitting in these
very seats in um
in less than 24 hours for the private q
a on on my patreon you can find it there
there will be a link up shortly at 11am
on sunday may that's gonna be 29th
and uh then we will be back in a week in
june
in june
that sounds so much sunnier it does it
does sound so much sunnier
but until then until then be good to the
ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
[Music]
[Music]
you